Hey everybody, it's Mike. Good
afternoon. It's um what is it? It's the
April 15th uh 2025 and thanks for coming
out to this special presentation on the
order flows catalyst for Ninja Trader 8.
You know, I'm excited to bring it to you
because it's something that um you know,
a bunch of people have been asking about
it. they they've seen
um some of the output from it and asking
for more information on it. We just
released it yesterday. Honestly, I
wasn't planning on on releasing it, but
uh you know, the traders that I had
talked to about it were very interested
in seeing it for
themselves. So, um you know, before we
begin, just a couple things. Yes, there
will be a recording of this uh webinar.
uh you will get it uh later this
afternoon as well as it'll be posted on
the YouTube channel and you know if you
got any questions put them in the chat.
I'm going to try and keep this short.
I'm not going to go on and on uh for
hours. So, um, you know, I will get to
the questions at some point, but, um,
you know, for now, uh, if you got any
questions, just be sure to put them in
the chat and, uh, you know, later
towards the end, I'll take a look at the
chest the, uh, the recordings, sorry, at
at the questions. So, again, yes, there
will be a recording. It is being
recorded and we'll go from uh, we'll go
from there. So, again, you know, brief
disclaimer, you know, trading does
involve risk. only trade with money that
uh you can uh afford to use as uh
trading capital basically. You know,
we're all adults. We all understand
that. So, let me ask you, you know, what
do you why are you still missing high
probability trades? You know, maybe it's
because you're drowning in market noise
and confusing signals. you know, the
issues with uh orderflow is, you know,
especially traders that are new to order
flow, they tend to get confused with
what they're looking at. And, you know,
I've always been wanting to build tools
for traders that help them understand
what they're looking at in the order
flow. I mean, it's pointless to look at
order flow and try to trade it if you
just don't know what you're looking at.
You know, I see that uh over the years
with traders, not just with a footprint
chart, but traders trying to look at,
you know, the the dome, the depth of
market, and you know, they think they're
just going to pick it up right away. And
that's not usually the case. It does
take some time before you get uh up to
that level. And that's why I create
tools for traders to help them along in
their trading journey. You know, maybe
you're frustrated by using indicators
that lag the market, right? that are
telling you what already happened. You
know, it's looking back, you know, in
the past and not actually taking into
account what's happening right now. You
know, maybe you're getting caught by
false breakouts or weak reversals, you
know, moves that look like it's about to
happen, but then just sort of fizzle
out, right? Or maybe you just lack true
insight into the buying and selling
pressure that's taking place in the
market. Right? Now
even basic order flow does have
limitations as well as you know your
standard technical analysis right it's
it's not something that you know
especially if you're newer to the
markets makes sense right away right you
have to uh understand what you're
looking at right and again if you're
using lagging indicators that are price
derived you're always going to be behind
the curve you want
to be making trading decisions based off
of what is happening right now you Well,
even in order flow, right? People think
imbalances are the way because they're
looking at
um you know, the aggressive trading
taking place and that's all that
matters. It's not. It's just one piece
of the puzzle and often when they they
see an imbalance, they don't understand
it in the whole context of the market. I
mean, an imbalance by itself could just
be a big order that hit the market,
right? Nothing more than that. And if
there's no uh follow through, so the
imbalance doesn't mean anything, right?
Traders ignore how the market trades.
They don't differentiate between
aggressive and passive traders
effectively. You know, if you're looking
on a normal candlestick chart, you can't
see where the aggressive traders are
taking place. I know a lot of people try
to guess, you know, I see videos where
people say, you know, looking at a
simple bar chart, oh, there's aggressive
trading here. Well, how can you how can
you say you're looking at a candlestick
chart or a bar chart when there's no
volume involved, say aggressive traders
were active here? You don't know that.
Um, and another problem people face is
they ignore when order flow matters,
right? They don't adequately factor in
market conditions like momentum. It's
one thing to look at order flow, but
again, order flow doesn't always uh
reveal everything. A lot of times all
you're looking at in the order
flow is just the facilitation to trade
between buyers and sellers. I mean
that's why markets exist is is to
transfer risk from one party to another,
right? For for risk takers to take on
risk and people that want to uh take off
their risk, you know, hedge themselves,
you know, they come to the futures
markets and that's what makes up the
order flow. However, there are times
specific times when what is taking place
is something bigger than just a transfer
of risk. just something bigger than the
facilitation of trade. And that's what
you need to identify in the order flow.
Okay. Now, when it comes to watching the
order flow, the secret isn't just
watching aggressive traders, right?
Looking at, oh, there's a there's an
imbalance in the market. That's what
everyone looks for in the order flow.
And it is important, but again, you got
to take it in context.
And what we've found over the years of
of trading and analysis is it's not how
there's not just that there's aggressive
traders present, right? It's you need to
understand how the volume how that
aggressive trading is being distributed
between both, you know, the aggressive
traders and the passive traders, right?
And when it matters the most because
again, you know, there's always
aggressive traders. There's always
passive traders. Aggressive traders
trade against passive traders. All
right? But depending on how it is
distributed throughout the bar and
throughout the market is what matters
the most. So introducing the order flows
catalyst, right? This is going to be
your edge in reading aggression,
distribution, momentum, and point of
control. Now what is distribution
discrepancy? Well, you know markets
trading a two-way auction, right? And
basically you had to deconstruct that
it's aggressive traders against passive
traders,
right? Aggressive traders
buy or sell the passive traders. Think
of it this way, right? You you're for
those of you that maybe are a little bit
newer to analyzing order
flow. Say you're going to look for a
car, right? You want to buy a new car,
okay? and you know, you go online, you
you pull up whatever to to look for, you
know, a new uh Chevy Trailblazer, okay?
And you see, oh, this dealer has this
this car listed for $30,000, okay? He's
a passive seller. The car dealer is the
passive seller. You're the buyer, right?
You want to buy the car. Now, you don't
know if you're aggressive or passive
yet. If you need a car, you're like,
"Sh, I need a car. I need to get to
work. $30,000. which I'm fine with. I'll
pay that. Then you'll become the
aggressive
buyer. Okay. Now, if you are sitting
there and like, h, you know what? I I I
want a new car, but you know, my car is
okay. It's lasting for a while. Um, but
I like this Trailblazer, but I I don't
want to pay, you know, $30,000. You go
into the the dealer, you kick the tires,
and you just sort of like, yeah, you
know what? I'm um I'm interested in it,
but it's just too much. You know, you
got any special deals you could
do and you have a a price in your mind,
right? Again, $30,000, you're not
interested. But you know what? Hey,
maybe at at 27 you'd be interested, you
know, and the guy's going to say, "Oh,
yeah, I could take this. I could lower
the price. you know, I got this um thing
going on, the special going on, or maybe
the dealer in the back of his mind has,
you know, a truckload of Trailblazers
coming in next week. And he's like,
"Okay, you know, I got to move this
car." Okay. He'd be like ask you, you
know, what where would you be interested
at? You know, what what's your budget?
And you say, you
[Music]
know, 27,000. And he, this guy knows
that he's got like 50 of these things
coming in next week. He's going to say,
"Okay, fine. I'll give it to you."
27,000. You become the passive
buyer. The car dealer became the
aggressive seller. He moved down to the
market price cuz it's 27,000 right now
cuz that's what you're willing to pay.
Okay? So, you know, you have to
understand how the two-way auction
works. It's not just a bid and offer.
You have aggressive traders trading
against passive
buyers. So, you have aggressive sellers
against passive buyers. you have
aggressive buyers against passive
sellers. Okay. So, what catalyst does is
it analyzes the volume traded at the bid
and offer not just in the two-way
auction but up and down the bar. Okay.
Crucially, the catalyst looks for
discrepancies in how volume is
distributed between aggressive traders
removing who you know the traders that
are removing liquidity versus passive
traders who supply liquidity. Okay,
that's what a passive trader does.
They bid or offer in the market.
Aggressive traders trade generally at
the market. They buy the offer or sell
into the bid. So what this does is it
reveals underlying shifts in control
before price makes its big moves. Okay?
So again, it's not just about imbalances
taking place, right? I mean you see
almost every bar in this example has
buying imbalances or selling imbalances
and some bars have both buying and
selling imbalances right gave one signal
here to the long side okay it does have
one buying imbalance in it but you know
like I said almost every bar majority of
them have buying imbalances or selling
imbalance it's not just about looking at
oh you know there's a buying imbalance
that that's bullish right you you can't
think that way because again You don't
know what's causing it. It could be just
the result of a big order. You have to
look at how that volume that's traded is
distributed throughout the entire bar.
Okay. Now, context is king when it comes
to trading, right? That's why we have a
filter for momentum. Okay.
Because distribution discrepancy alone
isn't enough, right? The catalyst asks
basically is there momentum in the
market when the signal occurs. The point
of that being is it's going to filter
out noise in choppy markets. It confirms
signals during established moves or
potential breakouts because again at the
end of the day what you want to do is
trade with the market's underlying force
that is present.
And you can have the best analysis in
the
world. Doesn't matter whether it's
orderflow or or technical analysis or
fundamental analysis.
You put on a position, you get long in
the market. If nobody
else in the
world sees it at that moment, it may not
go in your favor. Right? Now, again, I'm
not talking about like uh, you know, a
10-year outlook of the market or, you
know, during subprime, right? You know,
where there was a few people that that
got short very early, but they took a
ton of heat, right? I'm talking about as
a day trader, as a short-term trader,
when you're trading intraday, right? If
you have a view of the market right now,
is the market going in that direction or
not, right? If if you don't have other
traders, which is the momentum behind
you, sort of the wind in your sale, it's
not going to go in that direction and
you're going to get stopped out. That's
just how it is. I mean, you know,
sometimes people, you know, will come to
me and and say, "Oh, Mike, I got this
this great system or method for trading
the market." You know, it's like, but
it's so
isolated that if other people aren't
trading in the same direction as you,
the market's not going to move in that
direction. What you want to be doing is
trading in the direction of the market
rather than fighting it.
So what we catalyst also looks at not
just volume how it's distributed in the
bar is also the point of control in the
bar right point of control think of
point of control as the bar's center of
gravity the point of control right is a
term from market profile right volume
profile which is the the price level
with the most volume traded at during
the day because you know market profile
volume profile traders generally look
at profile for the whole
day. Orflow traders look at it on a
barby basis. Okay? And it's it's on each
bar is going to have a point of
control. Okay? And it's kind of like the
center of gravity
where all the not all the volume the
most volume in the bar occurred.
So you have your choice with catalyst of
primary point of control or PC movement.
You can't use both at the same time as a
filter. I'm going to go into that later
when I get into some examples. And the
whole point is it adds weight to signals
in bars where the PC stands out
significantly because remember every bar
has a point of control but not every
bar's point of control matters.
And what you have to do is put it in
context with the market. Okay? Like I
said, you know, every bar has a point of
control, but just because it has a point
of control coming in at a certain place
is one thing. You have to put it in
context
with the rest of the volume trading in
the bar and not only in the bar itself,
but relative to prior bars. Okay? You
see these bullish ones, right? Again,
you know, we have point of controls
coming in at the bottom of the bars, to
the top of the bars, middles of the
bars. Fine. But when you have a point of
control, where it comes in matters in
relation to how the market is trading.
Again, not all point of controls are
important, but there are some that are
more important than others.
So what makes the catalyst revolutionary
is it can track PC movement across
price. Okay? Because when you track PC
movement within the bar and relative to
prior bars, it gives you clues as to how
the market is going to be moving. And
why this is huge is because it shows
where significant volume is actively
shifting. You know, if you have a rising
point of control, got potential
accumulation or buyers taking control
higher, right? That's why it's called
point of control. It's where the control
is in the bar. Falling point of control
potential distribution or sellers
pushing control lower provides dynamic
insight into institutional positioning
and directional
bias. Okay. So again we have this filter
on. It's called PC movement. The this uh
bargain showing you two examples. This
the same bars here. One has no PC
movement enabled. We have the signal
coming in here and it's not a good
strong signal, right? The market starts
trading lower, then it comes back up and
would have stopped you out. When you
have PC movement, right, you don't have
that signal coming in because you don't
have the the good PC movement that
necessary for the signal to fire off.
That's why there's no signal on the next
on this chart here on the right. Okay.
And again, it's important to to
understand how volume is not only
distributed in the bar, but how it moves
throughout a bar. Okay. Now, here's a
here's a quick chart, right? This is
just the catalyst signals not using the
PC movement. This, you know, it's going
to be for more general analysis, and
there's going to be times when you're
not going to want to um use PC movement,
which I'll get to shortly. But here's a
chart, same chart, exact same chart.
This is a ultrabond 2 minutes, right? No
PC movement as a
filter. Look at that. Much cleaner,
right? You don't have previous chart,
you got a lot of little signals going
off here. Some are good, some are bad.
You know, if you're a high frequency
trader, you know, that that takes a lot
of trades in and out, maybe you're not
going to use it. Okay? But if you're,
you know, on a sort of a different, you
know, I'll say a longer time frame. It's
a two-minute chart, but this is a
two-minute chart, right? And you see,
you know, you're catching the major move
up. I mean, there was a little short
down here. Okay. Stopped you out. Then
you caught it. Major move up, decent
move down, another decent move down,
nice move back up right there.
So, people are going to ask, you know,
why not just use PC movement all the
time? Well, you can, but again, it
depends on the chart type or market, you
may not want to use it. So, for example,
if you look at a very fastmoving chart,
like say again, you know, I know a lot
of guys that scalp, okay, that are
interested in this tool and if you're
scalping, you know, on say a 30-
secondond chart or or a three- range
chart, PC movement is going to be very
limited just because the bars are short
by the very nature of the chart. Okay?
Maybe there's going to be two price
levels that trade or three price levels
or four price levels, right? If you got
a bar with two price levels, one of them
is going to be the the point of control.
What movement is there? It's not going
to be anything. So by using PC movement
on fastmoving charts, you're going to
miss many
opportunities because it's not moving.
Okay? So, you know, in those instances,
you know, maybe you're not going to use
the PC movement. Okay? But if you're on
a normal one minute chart and you know
crude oil or or you know currencies even
yeah you can you can use the PC
movement. Okay. Now you know this is
sort of the beauty of order flows is
that you can see this information if
you're just looking at a normal
candlestick chart or bar chart. There's
no PC levels showing in the bar simply
because it's not part of the bar makeup.
Right? A candlestick chart or bar chart
is built on where price opens, the high,
the low, and the close. That's it,
right? It doesn't take into account
volume. And even if you're looking at a
bar chart and you have volume along the
bottom, well, that's just the bar's
volume. It doesn't take into account
where it actually traded inside the bar.
And that's why looking at order flow is
important. And the catalyst analyzes the
order flow so you don't have to. Okay.
What it does is it actually it's
programmed to analyze a footprint. It's
like having a footprint chart running
underneath your normal chart and it's
doing all the calculations, all the
analysis on the back end. So, it'll just
plot on a normal candlestick chart.
Okay? So, that's why, you know, you
could use it with a footprint chart. Of
course you can. But if you're not
interested in using it with a footprint
chart and you already have a bar chart
or candlestick chart that you use, you
can plot it on there, right? So you
could plot it on ex the existing chart
that you're already using, right? That's
that's the beauty of it because again,
you know, a lot of people aren't
interested in trying to decipher a
footprint chart simply because they have
their existing way of trading. they have
their existing chart type that they use
with maybe some other indicators and
they want to add another layer a layer
of orderflow analysis to their existing
method of trading. So, you know, enough
with the slides. You know, it's always
best to take a look at the market as
it's as it's trading. Okay, so let's
just
uh throw up a chart in here. Let me just
make this a bit bigger.
Okay, just bear with me
[Music]
here. Okay, that should be nice
and nice and big there. Okay. Whoops.
All right. So, again, you know,
adding catalyst is is very easy. All you
got to do is you just import it as you
would any Ninja Trader
indicator. Then once it's loaded, right,
you just click on here. Orderflows
catalyst. Your license token that you
get when you purchase the software is
necessary. You just drop it in there and
you only need to enter it once. It stays
on the back end. And these are the
default settings.
Okay. Settings are very simple,
straightforward. Um, I'll just run
through them really quick here. Now, it
does have multi-time frame analysis. So,
you could either analyze the existing
chart that you're on. So for example,
this is ultrabond one minute chart. Um
it would just be the chart period value
zero. However, if I wanted to analyze it
based on, you know, a 500 tick chart, I
could or you know a volume, you know,
maybe 2500 could a range, you know,
three, four, five range, three range,
simple. You can just put whatever range
you want to analyze and it will analyze
it on your existing chart that you have
open. So even if you have
a one minute chart open, but you want
the analysis from a three minute chart,
you can do that. Or sorry, from a three
range chart, you can do that. Or you can
even
go below your existing chart or above
it, right? So 30 seconds, you know, if I
have a one minute chart open, I want to
anal an
analyze a bit faster off a 30-cond
chart, I could, you know, just change it
to second, put 30 minute, you know, I
could go, you know, say I want to use a
three minute on a one minute, I could do
that, you know, a five minute um
analysis, etc. Okay, but you know, let's
keep it simple to begin with. the
existing
chart that I'm looking at. Right, this
is a one minute chart. Trade entry
signal. You know, this is something
that I have on just about all my
indicators and and what the point of the
trade entry signal is is it helps me
trade in the direction of the market,
right? Means when it's enabled, price
level in ticks means if it's a bullish
signal, the bar. So I have my signal
bar. The next bar has to move two ticks
higher than the signal bar over a
period. In this case, I have it set at
three. So within three bars after the
signal bar, it has to move at least two
tick. So I know the market's at least
moving in that direction. Now the
visuals, okay, I like to have zones. I'm
a big zone person, right? I like to draw
it out until tested just because it
helps me visually see that, hey, you
know what? There's a bullish zone or a
bearish zone. You know, you could have
it fixed or you could choose not to even
look at it. In that case, you would just
change it signal box width to zero. Um,
you don't have to worry about signal box
offsets and ticks. That's just, you
know, where it appears in the bar.
Signal box opacity, you know, how dark
you want the zone to be drawn out. If
you're using until tested, as long as
you have a value
above one and above for the signal box
width, it will appear. But if you have
it
fixed and you have signal box
with five, it will draw it out five bars
starting at the signal bar. Signal mark
displacement is where it appears. How
far from the bottom or the top of the
bar. All right. So, but these are the
important settings coming up here. So,
catalyst strength is one through six.
So, what that does is it measures how
volume is being distributed. One is the
lowest, six is the highest. Okay. So
three is, you know, middle of the pack,
mid-range. It's just sort of normal
distribution. But if you go
one, it's very lenient in how volume is
distributed. Go to six, it's as strict
as it comes. Now, there's an equals
filter. And there's there's some rare
instances that we found where when the
volume is equal at certain points in the
bar, either you want a signal or you
don't want a signal.
Um, we keep we've kept it in there. I
mean, it honestly the the
difference is minuscule. Maybe maybe one
trade or two trades a day, if that even,
but it was just something we decided to
keep in there rather than take out. Um,
but I'll show you some examples.
Prominent PC filter is one of the PC uh
filters. And again, if you know, if you
followed me for a while, you you do know
that prominent point controls are
important part of my analysis. It
signifies support or
resistance. Now, momentum
strength zero to disable. Default is set
to
two, which means there there's a bit of
momentum. The highest you can go is
actually six. So, if you go six, that's
the strongest momentum that's taking
place. One is sort of the weakest. you
know, sort of the first sign of momentum
picking up. You know, two is kind of a
mid-range. You know, again, you know,
two and three default is set to two, but
if you want, you know, at least some
momentum, two is a good starting point
as well as three. Now, PC movement.
Okay, this is what I was spending some
time talking about, right? This is our
our new tool, our new filter that we've
added in here that it means that there
has to be movement within the bar of the
PC, right? And it has to either be
bullish movement or be bullish movement
for a bullish bar or bearish movement
for a bearish bar.
Okay. Now, PLC. So to enable it, you
would click
on that little box there. And then you
can see underneath it is PC movement.
Okay? And this is kind of like a a
strength of the PC move. If you have it
enabled, okay, it's going to be, you
know, one and up. One is the lowest
movement.
You you can go as high as you want, but
it it it's not how much movement. It's
sort of the the the strength of the
movement. Okay. So, five, you know,
honestly, I use one, three,
five, 10. I I don't really go beyond
that. I I don't think you need to, but
um our default is set to five, but I'll
show you with some examples with
differences taking place. Now, we do
have a sound
alert. This other stuff um data series
setup visual. You don't have to touch
any of that. That's just, you know, what
you're analyzing, how it analyzes it.
and that it's visual is where that it
plots on the actual chart itself. Now,
you do have the plots. So, it's going to
plot blue for bullish signals, red for
bearish signals. Okay? Triangle up,
triangle down, up for buys, down for
sells. The width is default is set to
eight. So, it's a good size. So, I'm
just going to add it on here with the
default settings. Okay. So there move
that. Click on it again. So get fresh
one. So you see three, two, three for
strength, two for momentum. PC movement
is
off. And you can see up here in the
upper leftand corner it says
calculating. Okay.
So this is the ultra bonds
today. You see we got this nice trend
going up. So again, the filters or the
settings rather that you're going to use
the most is catalyst strength,
um, momentum strength, PC movement, or
PC filter. People ask me which one do I
prefer.
You can't use prominent point of control
filter and PLC movement at the same time
because they they you know one's more on
momentum. The other one is a bit on
support and resistance. So you know
you're using sort of opposite ends of
the spectrum
there. So this is the catalyst strength
at three which is mid-range. show you.
If you set it at
one, right, you're going to get more
signals, that's you can see here's
there's a few more. If you set it at
six, you're going to
get fewer
signals because it's much higher, right?
So, you can see here, didn't catch any
of that move to the upside
over. Let me just get the crosshairs up.
Get darker
here.
Crosshairs. This one
three. Okay. So, you see there's there's
fewer signals when it's set
to a higher strength. Okay. And again,
yeah, it depends on the market that
you're looking at as well what you're
going to set it to. Um, let's just go
back to the default setting of three.
Okay.
And I just show you with prominent point
of control filter
on with primary point control filter on
there's going to be fewer signals. Okay.
See coming in here as opposed to with it
off. Okay. Right. You saw more. Now
momentum strength again if I turn
momentum strength off meaning no no no
momentum I will get more signals
obviously okay because it's not taking
into account the market moving in that
direction and again why you know would
you want to use momentum filter disabled
well again you know if depending on the
chart you're looking at again this is a
one minute chart you know I I have a lot
of traders that trade shorter time
frames than one minute and they just
want to see all the signals, right? So
that's why they would use it as off.
Okay. Um you set it to six, which is the
highest
setting, you know, you you see fewer
signals than you saw obviously at uh two
or when it is off. Okay. And again,
basically what it does, it just comes
down to understanding the market that
you're trading because again, you know,
if you're on a market, you know,
honestly, these markets that were in are
going berserko because of everything
going on with the trade wars. Today is a
bit of a calm day. You know, it's nice
to come into the market where we're not
looking at a, you know, 150 point
overnight range in the equities.
Um, that being said, I don't know if
after the holidays things are going to
pick up and go crazy again.
Now, reset that back. Now, PLC movement.
Okay, so I'm going to enable PLC
movement. Well, let me just go back to
the normal chart so you can see the
default
setting. Okay, now PLC
movement default is set at five, but
I'll just show you with um well, I'll
show you with five. Okay. So, you see
there's there's the signals where
they're coming in. When you add the PC
movement, there's going to be fewer
signals because now it's looking for
those times where they get movement of
PC in a bar. Now, again, this is a one
minute
um ultrabond chart,
which bars don't necessarily have a lot
of price levels. Okay?
So you're seeing PC movement only on the
bars that have some
decent movement itself in the bar. You
know, like this bar from 11814 at a high
of 18. Okay. But a lot of these other
bars are just two ticks. So using PC
movement on this market where you've
only got, you know, a few ticks, you
know, three ticks in a bar isn't going
to be very effective.
So, it's up to you if you want to use,
you know, again, it depends on the
market. You got to be looking at the
types of bars that you're trading, how
they are in the market that you're
trading. Okay. Now, you know, that's set
at five, which is a little bit stronger.
If I enable it, set it set it at one.
Should be a few more
signals. All right. So setting at one,
you can see there's some decent signals.
Now back to the visuals, right? You can
see signal box mode until
tested, right? That's where these zones
are being drawn out.
Um the reason we draw out zones, okay,
not necessarily for the point of the
market trading back, you know, right to
that level. Maybe give you a buying
opportunity here. um you know like a
here you know but if you bought here you
would have stopped out sold here sold
here you know be stopped out there's
times where price obviously comes right
down to those levels there's times where
it doesn't come back to the level like I
said I'm a visual person
and sometimes just having a simple blue
up triangle or a red down triangle isn't
enough for me. You know, I like to see a
signal come
in and the market immediately move away
from
it, right? Where it doesn't even come
back to trade. Those, in my opinion, are
the strongest signals, right? See here,
here, here, here, taking place, right?
Yeah. It's nice that it comes back right
to the tick, right? To the tick and
rallies up. But really what I'm looking
for those the ones the strongest moves
are going to come when you have a a zone
being drawn out where it doesn't even
come back and test it at all. Right? And
you know the sort of the longer you're
staying away from that area the bigger
the move. Now that's using this visual
thing visual thing visual setting. You
can also have it fixed. So you see the
default is five, right? So if I have the
default five and I use it as fixed, it's
I still have a zone, but it basically
draws it out over five bars starting at
the signal bar. So 1 2 3 4 five and then
it just ends
automatically. Okay. If I don't want to
have any zones, so say for example, if
I'm using it until tested, okay, but
it's like, ah, you know what? I don't
want to have those zones. The signal box
within bars, just change
that to zero. Okay. So now all I'm going
to
see is just the up and
down triangles. Okay, which you know for
a lot of traders they're fine with. But
again, like myself, I'm a very visual
person. Um oftent times I've got
different markets I'm trying to look at
and follow and it's just easier for me
to have the zones drawn out. You don't
have to
um use the zones if you don't want to,
right? You can just simply disable it
right there. Very, very easy.
Um let me just talk here really quick
about So, let me just turn this off. Get
back to the the default settings. Okay,
so here's the default
settings. Now, the multi-time frame
analysis. So say you're looking at a one
minute chart but you
want to say use slightly higher time
frame. Okay for
example three minute anal 3 minute
analysis on your one minute chart. Well
you just change the period
type to minute period value is three.
So, it's going to give you signals based
on a 3minut chart, but it's going to
plot it on your existing one minute
chart. Cuz say, you know, say you got
some other um indicators
working, all right, that you're fine
with, you know, you're using certain
um you know, Ballinger bands or
something, okay? and you need it on your
one minute chart cuz you right now they
don't have the ability with Ninja Trader
unless you get something customcoded to
to use a higher time frame on a
different chart here. Say you like the
signals that you see on a threeminut
chart, you know, based off your research
of the catalyst. You could put it on
your existing chart like this. So these
signals that you're seeing is not based
off the one minute chart. These are
based off of a threeinut chart analysis.
you know, maybe
you're want to use, you know, a three
range chart instead. Now, it's going to
be you probably see a lot of signals
because three range chart is is very
quick. All right, you see up here it
says calculating. All right, so here's
your signals based on a three range
chart with the default settings. Of
course, you know, you could always um
adjust it, you know, however you want.
Um, you know, say you want to use
uh, you know, PLC
movement off the three range chart
analysis. You just, you know, you click
there. Okay.
So, you're seeing some nice moves take
place. Um, now again, you know, it PC
movements using the minimum because it's
a three- range chart. If I was on, you
know, again, you're not going to get
much movement. So, I don't
know. There's only three range chart.
You only got four price levels. Okay.
So, maybe, you know, you want to use
either a higher strength or catalyst
strength or a higher momentum
strength. Okay. So, here I'm going to
make the momentum strength
six. So, it's going to be the strongest,
right? So you see, and I'm just getting
those trades in the direction of the
market movement, right? You see this
whole move up, it's a lot of bullish
signals. There's no bearish signals
coming in, right? Because it's
identifying that the trend is
up.
Okay. Um, you know, set that, you know,
if I even wanted to, I can make the
catalyst strength as strong as as
possible. Again, this is a three- range
chart. So, it's a very fast underline is
a threeminut chart that it's an three-
range chart that it's
analyzing. So, you look at that with
catalyst strength at six, momentum
strength at six, right? What do you got?
You just
got bullish signal, bullish signal,
bullish signal, bullish signal, right?
That's it. You're seeing on that chart.
Um, you know, that's today overnight 2
in the morning here. Bearish signal.
Another bearish signal here. 5 in the
morning before the bullish signals came
in.
Um yesterday what' you have 6:00 in the
morning 6:30 bullish signal was a
bullish signal pulled back a bit.
Another bullish signal that was it again
you know this this is set very
strong and that's on the reopen last
night. you see last
night,
yesterday, nice move up, decent little
moves to the downside,
etc. Um, you know, even on, you know,
other markets, I don't know, Euro
currency. Again, this is a a
this what was it? It was a underlying
three range.
Catalyst strength six, mo momentum
strength
six. Okay, you see why we got that nice
sell-off taking place here in the
currencies. It's just bearish all the
way down. Bullish for the most part.
Again, you know, do you want to use a
three range? Depending on the market,
you know, maybe you want to use an eight
range
chart. Same settings, six and six. I
mean
again the default settings that come out
of the box with the
uh indicator are good for most markets.
It's your starting point. Okay. So let's
just go back. You know here's six and
six. This is an underlying eight range.
They got a you know the analysis that's
coming in is based you know this is a
one minute chart but it's doing the
analysis based off an underlying eight
range. You can see a bearish signal
here. bullish, bearish there, bearish
all the way down. Um, let's just go back
to the normal
chart. Oh, I tell you what. All right,
maybe you want to
go 30 seconds. Okay, again, six and
six. I don't know how it's going to
look, but let's take a look. Okay, so
this
is 30 second analysis. So, it's again,
if who would use a 30-cond analysis?
Well, if you like to trade on a very
shortterm basis, okay, remember every
trade should start out as basically a
short-term trade or or a scalp. If it
doesn't work out, fine, you cut it. But
if it starts working out, you try and
write it. Uh but anyway, let's just uh
go back to the existing chart, right?
The one minute chart. Go back to the
default settings three and
two. And let's just talk about
uh
PLC prominent PLC and PLC filter. So
this is right the underlying chart right
one minute chart default settings
um PLC movements.
Okay. So currency you get good movements
on the chart. So we're going to use the
uh enable PC movements. And you can see
on the chart, you know, nice bearish
signal here, bullish
here. There was a bearish one. You know,
it's a little move. You know, this
market is exaggerated nowadays. But, um,
you can see it started selling off then
just went
sideways. This is why I like using these
zones because they do give me a level
that if the price gets back up to that
level or back down to this level, if I'm
in the trade, I should I should get out.
You know, I use it as a stop level. You
see here, nice move down. This one stops
you off, but then you get re back into
the trade here to catch that whole move
down.
Um, let's go back to the settings
here. Okay. So again, that's
what you know, we you could play around
with. You know, if you don't want to use
momentum, you're going to get a lot of
signals. If you're not using
momentum, maybe you want to keep the
catalyst strength stronger because
you're going to get, you
know, these what I call false starts,
right? Where it looks like it's going to
start moving and then it just fails.
Um but by setting the strength
higher catalyst strength higher six it
should give you the the stronger
signals. Another thing you can do
obviously is use PC movement if you're
not using momentum
strength. Again it's not about filtering
out trades. You you I'm a big believer
in trading in the direction of the
market. That's why we have momentum
strength in there. That's why we created
this PLC movement um in there as well.
So you can see there there's none in
here taking place on this move
down movement. Catalyst strength is
six. If I got it set at a lower number
three, it's as strong as you can go with
catalyst strength. Okay, see in there.
So maybe for this market five is too
strong for PC movement, right? So, if I
am looking at the market and I'm like, I
don't see, you know, hardly any signals.
There's a bearish signal on the right.
It's a bullish signal here, then I know
I know the strength for PLC movement is
too strong. So, I would back off a
little
bit to one, right, as my starting point
because I'm using it. I'm not going to
put it at zero. You can't set it at
zero. You just disable it. But now at
one, okay, I'm seeing some decent trade
opportunities.
um you know taking place.
Okay, you can see just going
back overnight since last night, you
know, at 8:00, right? Beautiful trend
up. All right, and again, you know, the
nice thing about the catalyst
is you really only got to worry about
catalyst
strength, momentum strength, prominent
point of control filter, or enable PLC
movements. It's either or, right? You
can't have both. You can't have
prominent point of control and PLC
movement, right? See if I I'll enable
both of them, right? Actually, there is
one signal there.
Surprisingly, okay, but generally
speaking, you don't
get signals. I mean, you know, that's
coming
in very illquid time, but during the
course of the trading day, it's going to
go
against each other. Okay? So, you're not
going to have them both on there at the
same time. So, since
there's basically it's just catalyst
strength, momentum strength, and the
PLC, either prominent point control
filter or enable PC movement. Okay.
So default settings is a good starting
point for all
markets. And again, you know, this is
eurourrency, right? This was yesterday.
Um, you know, Japanese
yen, right? This is going to be your
starting point for again, you know, all
the markets. I mean, currencies tend to
move together. uh you know if you're on
a market like say
gold or crude oil right
that you know gold is uh can be volatile
at
times you probably want to either set
you know maybe the strength higher or
enable PC
movement.
[Music]
Um so I'm going to enable it here so you
can see it's cleaning up a bit here.
right? You see that's not a good trade
there.
So, you know, maybe you're going to
adjust your catalyst strength to take in
a little bit more of the volatility. If
you're going to trade, you know, a
rangebased chart in gold, I don't know,
people always ask me, you know, what's a
good what's the best chart to trade?
What's the best market to trade? Well,
it really depends. There's no best
market. there's a good market for
everyone to trade. But if I was looking
at a market like gold, you know, I would
use the multi-time frame
analysis on a rangebased chart just
simply be and the same thing would I I
would, you know, for other markets that
are a bit volatile such
as YM and
Q, I would use a rangebased chart simply
because
there's then it's doing the analysis
based on price movements in the are as
opposed to um you know time. I mean you
can still look at a time based
chart but with these more volatile
markets you know we're just back and
forth trading up and down it seems to
make you want to pull your hair out when
you're looking at a footprint
sometimes using a rangebased chart does
help out a bit. Okay, so this is the
rangebased chart analysis on the
timebased chart. And again, you know, I
could use I could make the strength
higher. I could change the momentum
strength to, you know,
six. I do have the PLC movement on here.
Again, it's set at one, which is
its
minimum. All right. So again, you know,
it looks like it's a choppy market, but
again, this range
is, you know, 20 29 up to what 40. So
it's uh
42. So about $14 range, but there's
there's decent trades to be had from the
bottom to the top, from the top back
down.
Okay,
now I just want to go over this really
quick. Some of these settings, okay, so
again, like the default settings, you
know, I was talking about the multi-time
frame analysis. While you can use the
underlying chart, which is fine, people
always want to optimize it for the
markets that they're looking at. And as
I I sometimes I don't necessarily like
to
give fixed settings to people because
they they tend to want to take it fixed
in stone. You have to adjust it based on
the market, based on your own trading
profile. What do I mean by trading
profile is your risk profile. But for
bonds, bonds, currencies, grains, you
know, in addition to the underlying
market default settings, well, I have
PLC movement set at one. Try a three
range with a period, you know, a
rangebased chart with a period value of
three. If it's like gold or crude at 10
range, the same catalyst strength,
momentum strength, DLC movement. If it
was like something like YM or MQ, try a
25 range. Unfortunately, that's the
market conditions that we're in right
now due to the volatility. You
know, I I used to tra I mean, that's how
old I am, but I remember
trading well I am on on an eight range
chart. Now, there's no way you can do
that just because of the way the market
moves. Um, so if you're on a more
volatile market and you're
using if you're struggling with the
timebased chart, you know, look at a
rangebased chart. Okay?
So, think of the Orflos catalyst as your
new trading edge, right? It's going to
pinpoint high probability entries based
on true distribution and momentum. It's
going to filter out destructive noise,
which helps you trade calmer and avoid
chop. You're going to be able to see
hidden strength or weakness by
understanding aggressive versus passive
trading that's taking place in the
market. Because again, there's always
aggressive and passive trading taking
place, but how it trades, right? And
think of it, you know, if you ever watch
like car racing, you know, Formula 1 or
NASCAR, right? You always see the the
cars in front, right? And the real
activity is taking place, you know, the
the drivers jockeying for fifth place or
fourth place or third place, the back
and forth that's going on, right? That
that's the real race, right? That's sort
of the
hidden race that's taking place. And the
same thing in the order flow, right? you
have a hidden strength or or weakness
that's actually taking place beyond
where price is trading. Okay,
Shakespeare used to have, you know, all
his plays got the play within the play.
Think of it that way.
Um, being catalyst, you know, helps you
track volume control shifts by
leveraging unique PC movement
analysis. So, why is the overflow
catalyst different than, you know, any
of my other um indicators or any other
indicator on the market? Well, it gives
you true distribution analysis. It goes
beyond simple imbalance reading or delta
reading, right? And it takes more
holistic approach to analyzing the order
flow, right? It's got integrated
momentum context by filtering signals
for higher probability when you have
stronger momentum taking place. It's got
revolutionary PC movement tracking,
which is dynamic insight into volume
shifts. Okay? Because again, it's not,
you know, every bar trades volume. If
there was no volume traded, there'd be
no bar. What you want to do is you want
to track how that volume moves within
the
bar. Now, is the orderflows catalyst
right for you? Well, if you're a day
trader, scalper that needs precise
entries, yeah, catalyst is definitely
for you. If you're an orderflow or
volume trader seeking a deeper edge,
yeah, Catalyst is for you. If you're a
discretionary trader that wants
confirmation signals, right? So, you
know, maybe you're discretionary trader,
you know, some there are guys out there,
they shoot from the hip based on feel.
You know, having a tool like the
catalyst makes them feel better because
it it goes with their intuition, you
know, or maybe you're just frustrated
with your existing indicators that lag
the markets or or the noise that you see
going on in the market that makes it
difficult to trade. You know, if any of
these are you, then yeah, the catalyst
is right for you. Now, I got a special
offer going on, right, for the for
everyone. This is a webinar special and
this is for a limited time, right? The
normal price is going to be
$5.99, but for now, you can get it for
$279. So, just go to
orderflows.com/catalyst.com and it's
going to take you to the sales page,
right? It just looks like
this, right? You can see here
orderflows.com/c catalyst. Uh you just
you know there's a lot of information
about it how it's what it looks at in
the order flow some examples on how it
works with the candlestick charts. Um
you know talk a little bit about trade
entry
signal. All right. See the all this is
explained, right? All the settings are
explained in the user guide and you got
two ways you can pay either by Stripe or
by PayPal. Again, you know, some
people love PayPal, other people don't.
That's why we've added Stripe. You know,
a lot of people have asked for it. Um,
you know, some
FAQs. You don't need level two data,
just level one to run Catalyst. Okay.
And there's no free
trials. You don't need an Orflow
footprint chart to run it. And it is not
a footprint chart. Okay? So don't think
you're buying this, you're getting a
footprint chart. No, it's an indicator
that reads data as it would if it was a
footprint chart. And it plots your
signals on a normal candlestick chart.
Okay?
And you do need to run tick replay on
Ninja Trader so you can see the
historical
plots. The license is good for one PC.
So if you want to run it on another PC
that is going to require an additional
PC and it's right now it's only
available on Ninja Trader 8. You know
there are some people out there that's
still on seven because they got tools
that have migrated to eight. But it ours
catalyst is only available for Ninja
Trader 8. Okay? And it's not available
on MT4 or five or Sierra Charts or you
know some you know Trading View or it's
not available on Google Charting. It's
only on Ninja Trader 8. So again you
just go to
orderflows.comcatalyst and it'll take
you to this page. Just scroll down in
there and yeah, you're saving over 50%
right now on the indicator. Again, it's
just for a short time, then the price is
going to go up. is actually this
tool was supposed to be part of a bigger
ticket package that you know a lot of
traders have been asking um for private
training one-on-one training and this
was supposed to be part of it but um but
that training is is out of a lot of
people's reach
um you know where you you work with me
trade with me and we sit you know on a
call together and we trade you know, the
markets, but
um not everyone is able to do that, but
I do want to get this indicator out to
everybody that is interested in it.
Um, okay, there's there's a few
questions here. Um, yeah, there's going
to be a
recording, so don't worry about that.
Um, some people are asking about an NQ
chart and an ES chart.
Yeah, sure. Let me
uh pull one up here. So, what do I got
here? Gold.
Well, okay. So, this is a 10 range
chart. Again, I I was talking earlier
about using a rangebased chart to
analyze on
a NQ.
So, we'll pull up
NQ. Now, again, you know, the problem
with NQ is especially again, you know,
today is kind of a knock on wood, a slow
day relative to how the market's
been for the last week or
so. Because if you remember looking at
ENQ, you're getting some insane
movements and and even you still are.
And again, you know, people say put it
on ENQ chart. Not everybody uses a
timebased chart or you know I know
there's a lot of guys that use
rangebased chart other traders use
volume based
charts. I know other people aggregate
ticks on an NQ chart simply because some
of these bars I mean like here there's
there's a bar that happened around 9 you
know 920 which is about the bar is about
60 points wide. Um, this is on well, let
me just go back to the 25 range. Again,
you know, you're probably not going to
use 25 range, but let me just go back to
the underlying chart itself. We'll start
with the default settings, three and
two. Okay, there's going to be a lot of
signals probably, I would imagine. I
don't know because the catalyst strength
is set to three, momentum strength set
to two, but we'll sort of walk through
it because again on a market like
NQ, it doesn't trade the same
way these other markets out there trade.
You know, there's a hell of a lot of
volatility in NQ, especially during now
with the the trade wars that are going
on. And it does affect, you know, it's
almost like they they keep making these
changes, you know, recently for, you
know, Nvidia said, "Oh, they're going to
invest all these hundreds of billions of
dollars to build chips here." Obviously,
Nvidia, you know, Apple, etc. are
companies that are directly affected by
these trade wars that are going on. Um,
so you can see, okay, so this is the
default setting three and two, right?
these bars, right? Even though there's a
buy here, right, that that failed these
bars, 30 all the way up to 70, a 40
point bar, you know, that's not good.
You'd probably want to set momentum
strength
higher during the US session. You know,
this the um what do you call it?
Volatility is obviously a lot more than
during the night session. That's not to
say that during the night session you
don't get it because you can get
volatility
um during the Asian hours and even
during the European hours. But you know
we'll we'll try with momentum strength
set to six. You know it's probably set
PLC movement or honestly I know with
NASDAQ you don't get a lot of prominent
point of controls period just because
the bars are
too are too big, right? Prominent point
of controls are more for markets that
trade normally, not a market like NASDAQ
that can be all over the place. So here
I've set
the momentum strength at six. Okay, so
still a couple bad trades in
here. You know, this is a market that
you could catch some decent trends on.
You know, did catch the earlier one
where it moves from about 900 all the
way up to
100. Um, but
overnight again, you know, these
overnight moves, these big massive moves
taking place here. Like I said, I like
when you get the zones, that's why I'm a
big I hate to call myself a zone trader,
but when I see these zones that are
standing out over time and we sort of
come back to it and then move away from,
you know, I love those type of
trades. All right, but there's other
adjustments you can make. Again, I don't
want to spend too much time on it, but
you know, maybe you're going to use PC
movement. I don't know how it's going to
look. Maybe I'm going to set the
catalyst strength a
bit stronger at six. So, six, six,
you'll see movement at five. Again,
prominent point of control in
NASDAQ. I just know by looking at
NASDAQ, you don't get very many
prominent point of controls to begin
with. So, it's not one that I would
worry in a volatile market like NASDAQ
or MQ or even YM. those markets you tend
not to get a lot
of prominent point of controls. That's
just how the market is because again the
bars are very big because there's
there's just not a lot of liquidity
going
through. So let's just give it a second
here to calculate here. So again I got
this one very strict settings
six
five you know. So there's a bullish
signal. How's it that was last
overnight. It's how it is during the
day. It's not much signals during the
day. And again, you know, it depends
[Music]
on the chart type. This is just a plain
vanilla one minute chart. Um, let's move
to ES because there's a question about
pulling up an ES chart.
You know, there's there's a good 30 40
contracts out there in the world,
futures contracts that make
um good trading contracts beyond the
equity indices, you know, and and people
I I know it's glamorous to look at ES
and MNQ because the moves are very can
be very big, right? especially in in NQ.
Um, but to me, it's about picking
lowhanging fruit, right? Why bang my
head against the wall trying to decipher
NQ or MNQ when there's a lot of other
markets out there like I I show you the
interest rates, beautiful moves that you
can get in interest rates. So, this was
that same setting that I had just left
with NQ. So,
it's here. Let's go back here.
It was uh catalyst strength at six,
momentum strength six, PLC movement at
five, but we'll just go back to the
default again. I don't know how it's
going to
look. I'll keep the PLC movement
on. Like I said, today it's uh kind of a
calmer day. It's we're we're in a 40
point range more or less since the cash
opened. you know, basically from about
5440 up to
5480, which
is calm for this market. You
know, over the last few trading sessions
going back to last week, we had some
bars themselves were over 40 points. Um,
so just give it a second here because
it's calculating. Okay. So, that's kind
of similar
to what you saw on the
NQ. You know, I'm sure you could do some
adjustments to the settings to sort of
figure it out, but again, you know, why
bang your head against the wall? This is
right. This is the default
settings, right? Three, two, and five.
Well, turn off five. So, just three and
two. Catalyst strength at three,
momentum strength at
two. Okay, with the underlying chart
again with trade entry signal on
um let's just put it on there in the
ES. I did see a question here. Yes, uh
Yolanda should work with markers.
um basically using the PC filters from a
higher time frame to a lower time frame
and giving support and resistance using
PC versus just highs and lows. Yeah,
Mark uh in a way, you know, if you're
using higher time
frame, you if you're using that
multi-time frame analysis, right, you
would
be using so like if I were to change
that to say five minute, you'd be using
the five minute point of control, right?
if you're using a PLC filter, prominent
pointer control filter or PLC
movement. All right, so this is
the ES the default settings. Okay,
during the day
session, right, just going back to the
night, evening,
yesterday. Okay, but like I said, you
know, that's the default settings. you
probably want to dial it in a little
bit. But, you know, again, there's so
many markets out there you can
trade, you know, like on here, this is
British pound, but you see, you know,
like myself, I've got all these listed
in here. These are the markets I
regularly look at.
Um, you know, this is the default
setting. You know, if I were to
add some PC movement on
here, we would clean it up a bit. You
know, it's a nice buy, nice sell from up
here, catching that move down.
Um, you know, I don't know what else. I
like the currencies now. I think you're
getting some decent
movements. Uh, yeah, buns. You guys are
in Europe. Buns is a is a nice contract
to
trade.
Um, okay, that's with the now P using PC
movement in the bund. um you may want to
disable it simply because again, you
know, some of these bars are just, you
know, a couple of ticks. You don't want
to miss the move. Um but you could even
drill down to
uh also like I said, the three range
chart
underlying, right? catch some nice
movements. You know, this is the major
move of the day, right? We opened up,
started trading lower, going sideways,
then it drops from 25, 131, 25 all the
way down into the
1380s, right? You want to catch that
move as early as possible, but you're
seeing one signal, two signals there.
um you know just go back to the normal
chart
type. You even go down to catalyst
strength of
one. It's going to give you a lot more
signals. All right. See
here sideways. Boom. Drops down. Catches
the move up. Catches the move down.
Catches. All right. Catches that down.
Catches this move up. I mean, yeah,
there's a little bit of back and forth.
Move down. Move up. move down, move up.
Um, you know, regular bonds are US
bonds. The same setting, just leaving it
on
there. Catches that big move up, little
moves down. Again, if you're a
short-term trader, you're just looking
to scalping a few ticks, you know, this
could be for you.
Um, Stephen asks, let me see here. So,
again, you know, if you're interested in
the
[Music]
software, just go to this website,
orderflows.com/catalyst, the actual
underlying footprint chart. If you were
to get the footprint
chart, you just go to
orderflows.com
off eight. Whoops. Eight. Okay. The for
normal footprint chart is here. It's
$799. Okay, this
indicators, you see
here, although with this footprint
chart, you're getting the footprint,
you're getting a bunch of trading
courses as well. So, education that goes
with it, whereas the catalyst is just a
standalone indicator and it reads, you
know, people say, "What's the difference
between this and, you know, something
like the Delta Scalper?" Well, the delta
sculper reads specifically delta. Okay,
catalyst goes beyond delta to a
different level, right? It analyzes uh
PC movements, analyzes PC, but more
importantly analyzes the volume
distribution, how it's being distributed
throughout the bar, if it's bullish or
bearish. Okay, so standalone indicator
is 279, but again, price is going to go
up after
the normal introductory price. You know,
guys that that know me have been around
followed me when when I release a new
indicator, you know, for those of you
that follow me for the first week or so,
you're able to get it at a discount,
right? And right now, the discount is
about what is that? 599 to 279. So, it's
about
54%. So, it's over half
Okay. So, it's a great deal. Um, so jump
on board. So, again, just go to
orderflows.com/catalyst. I'll put that
link in the
chat. And again, you know, later today
once this uh video gets
processed, I'm going to uh I'll send it
out so you guys can watch it again. I
know some of you got in late or some of
you, well, if you got in early and had
to leave, you won't hear this, but um
some of you had to jump off the call
already.
But just uh be patient and you'll get
the replay later
and you know, if you don't get my email,
just check my
uh YouTube page. So, thanks everyone for
coming
out, spending your morning with me. I
know it's it's a kind of it's a holiday
week. We got Easter this Sunday. I think
we got Passover as well. So, you know,
again, you know, today is about as calm
as the market's been in a while. So,
it's good to get this uh session in and
I'll catch you guys later. Take care.
Bye-bye.